today's video is kindly sponsored by
hohn the at-home premiere men's health
clinic hey 42 here in february 2016
jupiter single-handedly prevented one of
the biggest bank robberies in history
saving the country of bangladesh just
shy of a billion dollars in the process
as unlikely as that may sound it really
did happen but to find out exactly how
i'm going to have to fill you in on a
bit of a backstory first bear with me
here because this is going to get a lot
more confusing
before it starts making any sense
there's lots of men all over the world
who probably feel that the older they
get the less motivation strength and
overall drive they have it's no shock
that men's bodies change over time and
they often become less efficient in
day-to-day life
this can be down to a number of factors
such as age the environment or even
stress and it's totally normal and
speaking personally
i've definitely noticed decreasing
energy levels over recent years
which is why i'm really excited to
introduce today's sponsor hohn helps men
to identify and address low testosterone
and then helps restore them to natural
levels with clinically proven treatments
hohn uses real doctors real science and
real fda approved methods to treat and
optimize your hormone levels
hormone optimization can have a huge
impact on your life from increasing
muscle mass decreasing body fat
improving focus stabilizing your mood
and helping you with stress management
but don't take my word for it after all
i'm not a medical expert although hohn
health is
and they'll be there with you every step
of the way so if you're ready to get
back to your best self with a
science-backed company that doesn't take
shortcuts then order hones easy to use
at home assessments today and take
control of your health and your future
to get homes at home testing and a
doctor consultation for only 45 dollars
click the link in the description below
or go to home health dot com forward
slash 42.
if i was to ask you who the greatest
golfer of all time was who would you say
tiger woods
jack nicholas
arnold palmer all good guesses but
ultimately you're wrong because the
greatest golfer ever to fondle a five
iron is none other than kim jong-il
former supreme leader of north korea and
father of the current incumbent kim
jong-un
don't believe me well in 1994 kim
jong-il shot a frankly astonishing 38
under par at the pyongyang golf course
just outside of north korea's capital
this truly remarkable round is said to
have included a birdie or better on
every single hole
and no fewer than five holes in one
for context tiger woods has only managed
three holes in one on the pga tour
across his entire career
the scrub
what makes kim jong-il's incredible
score all the more impressive is the
fact that he achieved it the very first
time he ever played golf imagine how
good he'd have been if he'd practiced
what you still don't believe me
well you don't have to take my word for
it the record-breaking round of golf was
widely reported on north korea's
state-sponsored news channel and if it
was on the news it must be true
i mean
why would they lie
okay so you don't need to tell me that
this whole story is also kim
jong-il has about as much claim to the
title of golfing goat as happy gilmore
and yet north korean news channels
really did report his record-breaking
ground across the country
that's a bit like bbc news claiming
boris johnson shaved six seconds off
usain bolt's 100 meter record whilst out
for a walk in the garden in his pants
thanks to mad stories like this one
elton john inspired nicknames
and frequent unflattering character
chores in some of the world's most
widely read newspapers and magazines
many people view north korea and its
leadership are something of a joke
so much so that it can be easy to forget
kim jong-un's democratic people's
republic of korea
is one of the only nine countries on
earth with a genuine nuclear arsenal
and it turns out it isn't just a nukes
we need to worry about because whilst
north korea's love affair with weapons
of mass destruction has been headlining
news for some time now
what's rather less well known is the
other military program the world's most
secretive state has been working on for
the past few years
north korea is training an army
of super soldiers
not muscle-bound schwarzenegger types in
science fiction-grade body armor you
understand
no
north korea is training a cyber army
a vast regiment of hacking warriors it
uses to lash out as its rivals from the
safety of the korean peninsula
and whilst this army fought to include
as many as 8 000 highly skilled hackers
is hidden beneath a cloak of secrecy
you'll probably have heard about some of
their more famous exploits in november
north korean hackers infiltrated sony's
computer systems ahead of the release of
the interview a film about a cia
assassination plot against kim jong-un
red skeletons appeared on the computer
screens of sony employees across the
whole of the us
forcing the company to shut down its
entire network for several days but
not before five unreleased sony films
were downloaded and released online
along with a raft of embarrassing
private emails sent between senior staff
then there is 2017's wannacry
ransomware crypto worm also thought to
be built by north korean hackers that
affected more than 200 000 computers
across 150 countries
in the space of just four days
wannacry was one of the most damaging
and far-reaching cyber attacks in
history
doing billions of dollars worth of
damage to hundreds of public and private
companies around the world including the
uk's national health service
but the thing is north korea is probably
the last place you'd expect to find an
elite army of hackers for starters it
has the lowest internet penetration rate
of any country on earth
in the uk around 97 of the population is
online
in nepal it's 36 percent and in
afghanistan it's around 11
any guesses for north korea
allow me to fill you in it's a smidge
over
just a few thousand users with heavily
restricted access
in a population of 26 million which
leads us to a rather obvious question
how can a nation that basically doesn't
have the internet
possess an army of hackers capable of
wreaking havoc all over the world
in most countries hacking is like
terrorism murder and poor queuing
etiquette frowned upon
that's why the vast majority of hackers
are self-taught you can't sign up to a
university course that'll teach you how
to craft the perfect fishing email or
carry out a first-rate ddos attack at
least
not in most countries
in north korea
things are a little bit different
the country's brightest mathematicians
are routinely plucked from the regular
school system as young as 12 and taken
to pyongyang the capital where they're
given intensive military-led training
designed to turn them into world-class
hackers
many complete further training in russia
or china but all are eventually sent out
into the world to begin sowing as much
online chaos as they can usually based
out of a country that you know has the
internet
perhaps unsurprisingly considering it's
basically made up of highly trained
geniuses
north korea's state-sponsored cyber army
has fast become an incredibly powerful
tool for the regime offering kim jong-un
and friends
a number of important benefits over
traditional forms of warfare
for starters cyber warfare is far
cheaper than its conventional
counterpart as you probably already know
even a really good computer costs less
than say an aircraft carrier
digital offensives also come with the
added benefit that they're far less
likely to be met with retaliation in
recent years we've seen
government-sponsored hacks attempt to
influence political campaigns
steal intellectual property from
world-renowned universities and spread
misinformation designed to subtly shape
public opinion
but unlike military offensives
these kind of cyber attacks are often
both hard to prove
and easy to deny
meaning the vast majority go unpunished
retaliating to north korea-sponsored
cyber attacks is even more problematic
after all it's hard to launch a cyber
counter-offensive
against a country that essentially
doesn't have the internet it's a bit
like living with a poltergeist it can
terrorize you it will
but no matter how tough you may be your
best moves can't hurt it
hacking isn't only seen as an offensive
tool in north korea either
it's also a financial one
you see north korea is one of the
poorest countries on earth with as much
as 60 of the population living below the
poverty line
for a more visual representation of just
how broke north korea is take a look at
the satellite image of the korean
peninsula at night
that's largely pitch black area you can
see that's north korea a country so poor
it literally can't afford to keep the
electricity on overnight
thanks to its ponchon for developing
weapons of mass destruction and
threatening to use them to blow the us
into another dimension north korea is
also one of the world's most heavily
sanctioned countries
meaning there isn't a long list of
nations it can trade with in fact
there's hardly any at all china accounts
for more than 95
of north korea's foreign trade hacking
gives the regime a way to generate cash
that no amount of sanctioning can
disrupt
and according to a 2019 u.n report
north korea's cyber warriors have raked
in some 2 billion for the regime
through a vast array of hacks both large
and small that's almost 10 percent of
north korea's entire gdp
generated through cyber crime alone
and it's here that we finally circle
back around to jupiter
and the billion-dollar bank heist i
mentioned at the start of this video you
see
back in 2016 a shady organization known
as the lazarus group which according to
the fbi is part of north korea's
state-sponsored hacking army
attempted one of the most audacious
cyber heists in history
the hack was incredibly sophisticated
and it started when members of the
lazarus group infiltrated the computer
network at the central bank of
bangladesh once inside the hackers were
patient they kept to the digital shadows
and over a series of months penetrated
deeper into the bank's computer systems
where they could observe how transfers
at the bank were completed
once they were confident they could
recreate and execute believable fake
transfers
themselves the team waited until the
bank closed for the weekend before
springing into action
using what they'd learned over their
months living as ghosts in the machine
the hackers created 35 fraudulent
transfers totaling
951 million dollars
all of which was to be withdrawn from
the bangladeshi government's account at
the federal reserve bank of new york and
sent to random bank accounts across asia
incidentally if you ever find yourself
strolling past the federal reserve in
manhattan you might like to know that
you're about nine meters away from the
single largest store of gold held
anywhere on earth including fort knox
resting on bedrock about five stories
down a half a million solid gold bars
worth well over 250 billion dollars
anyway the lazarus group's plan worked
flawlessly
almost
you see one of the bank accounts the
hackers were attempting to siphon the
loot into was located on
jupiter street in the filipino city of
manila
there was nothing particularly
interesting about this bank or about
jupiter street itself
but the presence of the word jupiter on
the transaction order
tripped a digital alarm in the federal
reserve's computer systems freezing the
payment
it's worth pointing out that none of
this had absolutely anything to do with
the lazarus group's hack
jupiter was the name of an iranian
shipping company that fell under u.s
sanctions
so
when that word showed up on a
transaction order it was automatically
held back for review
and when an employee at the new york
federal reserve took a closer look at
the batch of orders
it soon became clear
something was up
not only was it extremely unlikely that
bangladesh would suddenly decide to pay
close to a billion dollars to random
members of the public all over asia but
the payment orders themselves were
suspects with some including formatting
errors and spelling mistakes the
majority of the fraudulent transfers
were eventually blocked but four did get
through totaling 81 million dollars
it's crazy to think that had the hackers
chosen any other bank in manila a city
of 1.8 million people and literally
hundreds of banks the hack would most
likely have been a complete success and
north korea would have had an extra
billion dollars to spend on some shiny
new icbms
yeah let's all say a prayer of thanks to
zeus that they didn't
20 years ago cyber warfare essentially
didn't exist
today
it's one of the biggest threats facing
our society
it's long been said that the pen is
mightier than the sword
but i'm starting to think a really smart
person sitting at a computer with a
reliable internet connection trumps them
both
thanks for watching
good news you can now pre-order my new
book bread and circuses what did the
romans ever do for us it's a wild and
witty journey for a thousand years of
unexpected roman history
told in a refreshing way and packed full
of incredible and unbelievable stories
copies are selling out fast so pre-order
yours today to lock it in
thank you